let me ask you this
do you think that it's more likely
people were engaging this activity
before and the central intelligence
agency
didn't spot any red flags so what does
that tell you that tells you that either
the cia is so incompetent that they
couldn't spot maybe some disturbing
behavior with people who were looking up
thousands of child pornography images
paying for child pornography on cia
computers or devices i don't want to be
misquoted there i don't know if they
were using an iphone ipad or desktop
just to be clear so they are so
incompetent that they serve no purpose
or
they knew it and they recruited them
anyway and protected them anyway until
they got caught either way we're at the
point where the cia serves no functional
purpose again it the punishment needs to
be commensurate with the level of
helplessness of the victim i don't think
that there's any more easily viewable
easily on display grotesquely so a
differential in power than between a
child and a sexual predator